Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass, das Rückspiel der Copa Libertadores. Es ist jetzt endlich gespielt und wir wissen, wie der Sieger heißt, wie das jetzt alles zustande kam und was alles passiert ist nach unserem letzten Kurzpass zum Thema, das bespreche ich jetzt mit Andreas Geipel. Andreas Geipel natürlich, ach, da fängt es ja schon an. Andreas, hi, sorry. Da sieht man mal diese nicht vorbereiteten Intros, da verhaspel ich mich immer mal wieder. Schön, dass du wieder mal Zeit gefunden hast.
Ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen übrigens.
Ja, aber das muss dann doch korrigiert werden. Vielleicht war es ja auch nicht so deutlich. Also schön, dass du wieder mit dabei bist. Die Hörerinnen und Hörer kennen dich hoffentlich schon aus unserer Folge, die wir vor einigen Tagen aufgenommen haben, nach dem Hinspiel und vor dem Rückspiel der Copa Libertadores. Da haben wir lange mit dir darüber gesprochen, was bedeutet dieses Spiel, was ist zu erwarten. Wir hatten beide dann richtig Bock, du schon vorher, ich dann nach der Aufnahme. Ich war total gehypt. Und dann kam es ja alles ein bisschen anders. Und bevor wir über all das sprechen, was dann da passiert ist, rund um das Rückspiel, das nicht stattfinden konnte, würde ich gerne erst mit dem Sportlichen beginnen, weil eigentlich geht es ja ja ums Sportliche. Und dann wollen wir das Ganze andere besprechen. Also, lass uns mal beginnen. Das Finale River Plate hat es mit 3 zu 1 nach Verlängerung gewonnen. Wie hat es dir denn gefallen?
Also, ja, als das jetzt endlich angepiffen wurde, das Spiel mit diesem langen, skandalösen Vorlauf, war ich doch, ja, ich war ja schon enttäuscht spielerisch von dem Spiel, muss man so sagen. Es war gerade in der ersten Halbzeit schon sehr mühsam anzuschauen, gerade weil Boca Juniors auch total entgegen ihrem eigentlichen Spielstil also gar nichts gemacht hat fürs Spiel. Das war schon sehr überraschend, weil Boca ja eigentlich eine Mannschaft ist, die sich über viel Ballbesitz auszeichnet, die die Mannschaft im laufenden Turnier ist, die die meisten Pässe auch spielt. Und wenn du jetzt am Ende auf die Statistik guckst, dass da gerade mal ein bisschen mehr als 300 Pässe rausgekommen ist, ungefähr die Hälfte von dem, was River gespielt hat, ist das schon komisch, dass man in einem Rückspiel, in einem Finale dann tatsächlich so mutlos und so defensiv und passiv auftritt. Das hat mich negativ überrascht bei Boca. Und bei River ist absolut in Ordnung, dass sie gewonnen haben. Also war, fand ich, in beiden Spielen die bessere Mannschaft und hat es einfach verdient, wenn man insgesamt dann auch drei Rückstände umwiegen kann. Oder zweimal im Hinspiel den Ausgleich geschafft und jetzt auch im Rückspiel dann nochmal zurückkommt und das Spiel drehen kann. Ja, dann wirst du verdientem Champion. Da freut mich dann auch für River, dass das so ist und dass dann diese, sagen wir mal, doch etwas ängstliche Spielweise von Skeleto und Boca dann nicht mit dem Titel belohnt wurde.
Das hat aber wirklich zu einer zähen ersten Halbzeit geführt. Also River in der ersten Halbzeit mit zwei Schüssen, keiner aufs Tor, Boca immerhin sieben, wobei da wurde auch schon alles gezählt. Zwei davon gingen aufs Tor, eins war ja dann auch das eins zu null. Und in der zweiten Halbzeit war River auch noch lange Zeit, zwar Feld überlegen, sie hatten immer viel, viel mehr den Ball. Also am Schluss waren es genau 66,6 Prozent Ballbesitz, das kann man sich wunderbar merken, zwei Drittel, weil wir sind jetzt bei River. Und dennoch kam so wenig bei Raus. Wie entscheidend, glaubst du, war der Platzverweis ganz zu Beginn der Verlängerung?
Ja, Schlüsselzähne des Spiels, der Knackpunkt auf jeden Fall, weil Wilmar Barrios ist nicht zu ersetzen bei Boca. Es gibt zwei Spieler bei Boca, die nicht zu ersetzen sind, und das ist Wilmar Barrios und Christian Pavon. Und gerade Barrios ist halt, ja, es geht lauter Schlüssel, beziehungsweise Lieblingsspieler. Und der organisierte Spiel, der macht eigentlich keine Fehler, überragende Stellungsspiel, und dazu diese Zweikampfstärke. Und lustigerweise, Barrios ist noch nie vom Platz geflogen bei Boca. In seiner Zeit in Kolumbien ist das fünfmal passiert. Der ist gleich bei seinem Debüt damals sogar vom Platz gegangen. Aber bei Boca noch nie, also immer mal wieder für eine gelbe Karte gut, weil er es halt rumpeln lässt im Zweikampf. Aber man muss schon sagen, dass eigentlich beide gelbe Karten, also sie waren beide gerechtfertigt, aber es war eigentlich unnötig. Also in beiden Aktionen dieses Faul da, also so hinzugehen war, war nicht notwendig und eigentlich komisch für einen Spieler wie Barrios, der ja auch eigentlich vor so vielen europäischen Spähern gespielt hat, wo man ja im Vorfeld gesagt hat, na ja, hier gerade Barrios und Ezequiel Palacios von River, die spielen so ein bisschen vor. Und dass ihm dann so was passiert, war schon auch überraschend. Er hat an sich, hat auch nicht so gut gespielt. Ich glaube, er war das auch, gerade die Außen haben ja auch eigentlich nichts gemacht. Also Bufarini und Olassa haben sehr wenig gemacht. Da waren so zwei, drei Aktionen, wo er den Ball verlagern wollte, wo er den Ball dann jetzt ausgespielt hat. Wobei er eine gute Passquote hatte tatsächlich. Aber wo man dann auch gesehen hat, na ja, eigentlich, das war zwar sein Fehlpass, aber eigentlich so wie Boca spielt, hätte da der Außenverteidiger stehen müssen. Aber dadurch, dass man sich halt so eigentlich hinten reingestellt hat, wie übrigens, will ich mal noch kurz dazu erzählen, River hatte vor zwei Wochen, Ende November war das, war das Ende November, Ende November hatten die ja das Halbfinale in der Copa Argentina und haben da im Elfmeterschießen verloren. Übrigens mit exakt der gleichen Mannschaft, die jetzt im Finale gespielt hat. Und da war es eigentlich genauso, also das River, ich glaube die hatten sogar 75% Ballbesitz in dem Spiel gegen Gymnasia. Und Gymnasia hat es dann auch geschafft einen Unschienen über die Zeit zu retten und sich im Elfmeterschießen halt durchzusetzen. Und irgendwie habe ich so das Gefühl, dass Gelotto, der ja auch aus La Plata für Gymnasia auch gespielt hat, sich das Spiel angeguckt hat und gedacht hat, oh, da River kommt damit nicht so zurecht, so machen wir es vielleicht auch mal, weil ansonsten kann ich mir das gar nicht so richtig erklären, warum man da eigentlich so wenig probiert hat. Bauern zum Beispiel hat ja eigentlich eher im Mittelfeld gespielt, also geguckt, dass Enzo Pérez nicht so das Spiel aufziehen kann, weil über seine Seite war er ja gar nicht so aktiv. Und eigentlich müsstest du ja gegen River Druck auf die Verteidigung gerade über außen machen, weil die immer weiter aufrücken. Genau, und Kasco, die Schwachstelle, links Verteidiger Kasco, eigentlich die Schwachstelle ist bei denen. Und Piti Martinez, der vor ihm spielt, hat sehr viel nach vorne gemacht. Da hätte jetzt der Colombianer Villa eigentlich, da hätten sie mehr machen müssen. Aber Villa hatte ja auch sichtlich Probleme mit dem Ball, also hat er ja eine Aktion gehabt, wo er einfach den Ball schlecht verarbeitet hat. Und keine Ahnung, man kann natürlich jetzt sagen, so im Vorfeld, vielleicht sind es manche Spieler nicht gewohnt, auf so einem tollen Rasen zu spielen. Es war dann irgendwie 20 Grad Unterschied und was weiß ich, alles, naja. Aber mich hat schon überrascht, insgesamt das spielerische Niveau war doch schon schlecht eigentlich. Vielleicht waren sie auch nervös, aber ja, es war schon ein bisschen enttäuschend, muss man sagen. Spannend war es allerdings.
Ja, absolut hinten raus wurde es dann dramatisch in der Verlängerung. Und interessant ja auch, dass beide Tore in der regulären Spielzeit, in der es dann 1 zu 1 ausging, sind da beide Tore gefallen unmittelbar nach Situationen für den Gegner. Also einmal hat River eine große Konterchance und verpasst da völlig den Pass auf Außen. Und direkt im Gegenzugspiel nannt es diesen, ja, den schönsten Pass des ganzen Finals. Und Benedetto macht dann auch wunderbar das 1 zu 0. Und in der zweiten Halbzeit war es dann genau umgedreht. Da hatte Boca eine Chance. Es gab dann, glaube ich, Abstoß. Und dann ist direkt diese wunderbare Kombination von River gefallen, die auch einfach toll herausgespielt war. Es war dann am Schluss nicht mehr zu verteidigen. Pardadheit sagt so was. Man hat den Gegner schachmatt gesetzt. Also richtig, richtig gut. Aber das hat auch gezeigt, in dem Moment, wo die Mannschaften in ihrer Ordnung waren und quasi ihren Matchplan verfolgt haben, haben sie sich weitgehend neutralisiert, weil auch eine Mannschaft, vor allem die Juniors, sich komplett aus verteidigen erstmal verlegt hat. Und nur in den Momenten, wo die Ordnung mal aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht da war, da wurde es dann ein bisschen spektakulärer. Und dann in der Verlängerung in Unterzahl Boca, Ultra Defensiv, River mit vielen Chancen. Aber ja hinten raus noch mit dieser Dramatik, dass nach dem wunderbaren 2 zu 1, diesem Schuss an die Unterkante der Latte von Quintero, dass da eigentlich noch das 2-2 fallen kann mit dem Pfosten-Schuss in der 120. Dann die Ecke, die dreimal ausgeführt werden muss. Gefühlt haben sowieso ganz viele Aktionen sehr, sehr lange gedauert. Ein einfacher Freistoß hat manchmal vier Minuten von der Uhr genommen. Es hat mich wahnsinnig gemacht. Ich könnte keinen argentinischen Fußball gucken. Fürchterlich. Es wird auch so aufgebauscht, und dann hauen sie den Freistoß völlig unmotiviert auf Kniehöhe in die Mauer. Und dann denke ich mir, dafür jetzt? Und dann eben das Empty-Net-Goal, das 3 zu 1. Das war dann so ein bisschen die Gacinowitsch-Hommage von Martinez. Und damit war die Nummer durch. Aber eigentlich ja interessant, dass es dann auch trotz Unterzahl am Schluss noch so hoch dramatisch wurde.
Also erst mal noch mal kurz zu diesem echt tollen Tor, zum 1-1. Also das ist typisch River, genau dieser Spielzug. Man kann sich, wenn man denn will, noch mal das 1 zu 0 im Achtelfinale gegen Racing angucken. Das war eigentlich genau das gleiche Tor. Und mit der Einwechslung von Quintero, der ja relativ früh schon für Poncio kam, der eigentlich so der Passgeber ist. Aber im Finale war das ja Enzo Pérez, der auch über 100 Ballkontakte hatte, der allein mehr Pässe gespielt hat, als das gesamte zentrale Mittelfeld von Boca zusammen. Also muss man sich mal reinziehen. Nandés, Barrios und Pablo Pérez spielen genauso viel Pässe wie Enzo Pérez alleine. Wahnsinn. Und dann kam halt Quintero rein. Und seit seiner Einwechslung ging das ganze Spiel von River über rechts, weil er sich rechts eingeordnet hat. Nacho Fernández war ja auch auf der rechten Seite. Dann ist Enzo Pérez ein bisschen zurückgegangen. Und dann haben sie diese Dreiecksformation gespielt. Das ist also ein Musterangriff, wie Garciardo ihn trainieren lässt, wie man schon oft gesehen hat bei River. Und leider muss man sagen, dann später aus Sicht von Boca, beim Stande von 1 zu 1, als Quintero diesen Traumschuss auspackt, finde ich ein Fehler wiederum, weil Yada, der eingewechselt wurde, der auch kein defensiver Mittelfeldspieler ist, ihn ja dann doch kurz aus den Augen lässt und dadurch hat er die Chance, da so abzudrücken. Und dann war es natürlich schwer für Boca. Einer weniger, dann hast du noch 6-7 Minuten zu spielen, dann hast du eine Ecke, und dann kommen dann 1.93 Tormann und Andreas nach vorne. Das war natürlich vielleicht aus europäischer Sicht ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig, dass so früher Tormann mitkommt. Aber dann hat wiederum Yada, der so ein bisschen schlecht aussieht beim 2.1, diese Schusschance und trifft nur den Pfosten. Und bei dieser Chance meine ich, dass Boca sogar nur noch zu neun war. Gargo ist ja, ich glaube, direkt davor vom Platz gegangen, weil er sich die Achilles-Szene gerissen hat. Das ist das dritte Mal für Gargo, dass das passiert. Alle drei Mal, das ist auch unglaublich eigentlich, alle drei Mal im Spiel gegen River Plate. 2015, 2016 und 2018. Jeweils, je die Achilles-Szene gerissen hat. Also immer gegen River, das gibt's gar nicht. Es gibt sogar fünf Verletzungen. 2013 Muskelfaserriss, 2014 Bänderdehnung und die dreimal angesprochenen Achilles-Szene-Risse. Das Gargo, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht, ich hätte vielleicht dann gesagt, da komm, wir nehmen ihn nicht mit. Wer so eine Verletzungshistorie gegen River hat, den lässt du vielleicht besser zu Hause. Weil du kannst ja, weißt du, wenn einer immer ständig ausfällt, weiß ich nicht. Und dann waren sie halt nur noch zu neunt. Und letztendlich, ja klar, also es lag dann auch in der Luft entweder Kronburg halt doch noch irgendwie zum Ausgleich. Und so ist es halt nicht so passiert. Und ja, und dann ist halt Piti Martinez hat dann auch den Empty Netter gemacht. Aber wie gesagt, absolut in Ordnung. Viel, also der war einfach hochverdient. Der Sieg kann man nicht anders sehen.
Und wie hast du die Stimmung empfunden? Weil es war ja zum ersten Mal seit mehreren Jahren, dass wieder Fans beider Mannschaften in einem Stadium waren, wenn auch jetzt nicht in Argentinien. Aber war das anders? Hatte das einen anderen Einfluss auf das Spiel, als es sonst gewesen wäre? War das jetzt mutmaßlich, wenn es in Argentinien gespielt worden wäre?
Also ich fand die Stimmung, die war jetzt nichts Besonderes. Also es war schon okay, es war ein Finale. Dementsprechend war die Stimmung nicht schlecht, aber das kannst du ja nicht vergleichen mit, was los gewesen wäre, wenn das im Monumental stattgefunden hätte. Was los gewesen wäre, vor allem, wie hätten die beiden Teams performen, wenn es tatsächlich im Monumental gespielt worden wäre? Da steht ja was ganz anderes auf dem Spiel. Du bist in Madrid, da sprechen wir vielleicht später drüber. Aber von der Drucksituation, der Spieler her, ich weiß gar nicht, für wen das besser gewesen wäre, das tatsächlich im Monumental zu spielen. Natürlich hast du den Heimvorteil, aber du kannst natürlich auch eine historische Niederlage einstecken in deinem eigenen Stadion, vor deinen eigenen Fans, wo kein einziger Boca-Fan ist. Das ist natürlich auch für den einen oder anderen eine riesige Drucksituation. Da kannst du natürlich auch schnell nach hinten losgehen. Und die letzten Spiele hat Boca im Monumental eigentlich immer gut ausgesehen. Meistens sogar gewonnen. Ich glaube, ich habe es vom ersten Match, beim ersten Gespräch, schon erzählt, dass bei diesen beiden Duellen in den letzten Jahren halt oft die Auswärtsmannschaft einfach besser ausgesehen hat. Und es liegt vielleicht auch echt daran, dass du vor heimischer Kulisse dann doch ein bisschen gebremst wirkst, weil du keinen Fehler machen willst, und bei der Auswärtsmannschaft, die spielt so ein bisschen befreiter auf. Also, ja, weiß ich nicht. Also alles in allem halt sowieso sehr unglücklich, aber da sprechen wir ja später nochmal ein bisschen drüber.
Ja, ich würde fast sagen, dass wir da jetzt mal so langsam hinkommen können, was eigentlich so passiert ist, nachdem wir miteinander gesprochen haben. Es war nicht das letzte Mal, dass wir Kontakt hatten. Logischerweise haben wir dann relativ früh uns miteinander verständigt, was da alles passiert ist. Lass noch mal zurückspringen jetzt zum Tag des eigentlich angesetzten Finales in der –das ist jetzt auch schon zwei Wochen, glaube ich, her, zumindest gefühlt ist es schon ewig her. Und dann passiert eben dieser –also der Boca Juniors-Bus wird beworfen mit Flaschen und anderen Gegenständen, Scheiben gehen zu Bruch, Spieler erleiden Verletzungen durch herumfliegendes Glas und wohl auch wegen Tränengaseinsatz der Polizei. Und Boca weigert sich zu spielen und ist auch nicht spielfähig. Wir haben unmittelbar da auch schon angefangen, miteinander zu schreiben und du warst sehr emotional, weil du gesagt hast, das ist für den argentinischen Fußball mit das Schlimmste, was jetzt passieren konnte. Mit ein bisschen Abstand, wie würdest du das einordnen?
Also ich bin immer noch angepisst von der ganzen Situation und das wird auch, glaube ich, noch eine Weile andauern. Ja, es ist eine große Niederlage für Argentinien, für den argentinischen Fußball, für die Fans. Also man muss sich ja auch mal vorstellen, also dein Team spielt, du hast das erste Spiel und Unschienen gespielt beim Gegner, du durftest nicht rein ins Stadion, jetzt hast du eine Karte, gehst dahin und wartest dann 7, 8 Stunden in dem Stadion und es passiert nichts und keiner sagt was. Und du sitzt da, da ist es ja auch noch Sommer, da ist es ja richtig heiß und irgendwann sind natürlich auch mal die Getränke alle und da stehst du dann da halt so dumm rum, sag ich jetzt mal, sitzt da so blöd rum. Und ja, was halt draußen vor dem Stadion passiert ist, ich sag mal so, das ist jetzt mal generell nichts ungewöhnliches für einen argentinischen Fußball, dass sowas passiert, dass Busse beworfen werden, dass es natürlich in so einem Finale passiert. Also eigentlich, der Auftrag der Polizei wäre ja nur gewesen, diesen Bus irgendwie in dieses Stadion zu bringen. Also hast ja nun nicht mal die Fan-Problematik. Dadurch, dass keine Auswärtsfans erlaubt waren, hattest du eigentlich nur eine Aufgabe. Und das ist dieser Bus, dieser eine Bus muss in dieses Stadion.
Und wird dann wohl auch an der Straße vorbeigeführt, wo eben besonders viele River Plate-Fans stehen, was wohl gar nicht so die normale Route hätten gehen sollen.
Genau, das kommt noch mal erschwerend dazu. Warum sowas passiert? War sowas ein Fehler? Ist sowas irgendwie dann doch von Lagerhand geplant? Der Minister für Innere Sicherheit ist ja ein Familienfreund von Angeliki, vom Boca-Präsidenten. Man sagt auch, die Spieler von Boca, die dann im Krankenhaus waren, wurden von einem boca-nahen Ärzten versorgt. Ich weiß nicht.
Bewegen wir uns natürlich auf Mondlandungsverschwörungstheorien.
Es gibt sehr viele Theorien dazu. Alles in allem muss man sagen, das sind natürlich Aktionen, die nicht passieren dürfen. Ich finde es auch absolut in Ordnung, dass das Boca da nicht spielen wollte.
Es ist ja eigentlich auch wichtig für die Fans, das zu spüren, so hart es ist. Aber da ist halt auch was passiert, was überhaupt nicht akzeptabel ist. Und zwar in keinem Universum dieser Welt, unter keiner Verschwörungstheorie dieser Welt. Und dass man dann dafür die härtest mögliche Strafe, nämlich, dass dir das Heimspiel genommen wird, spürt, das ist natürlich im Einzelfall dann trotzdem tragisch. Aber im Grunde muss das ja schon so sein. Also Fehlverhalten muss ja Konsequenzen haben, auch wenn ich mir jetzt anhöre. Mein Gott, ich glaube, ich war noch nie näher an der CSU in meinem Denken.
Na klar, du bist ja auch Papa, vielleicht. Du hast absolut recht. Das muss bestraft werden, ob jetzt die Konsequenz daraus ist, das Spiele nach Madrid zu verlegen, die Copa Libertadores tatsächlich, also eine Copa für die Befreier und dann fast in die Hauptstadt der Gegenbewegung quasi zu verlegen, ist natürlich ein Schlag ins Gesicht an sich. Aber hast natürlich die Banco Santander, das Hauptsponsor von der Copa Libertadores. Banco Santander ist eine der wichtigsten Banken in ganz Spanien. Weißt du, da passieren halt irgendwelche Geschäfte. Es gab ja auch noch andere Städte, die sich da beworben hatten, über Genua, über Miami, über Asuncion oder Qatar. Also es gab ja Möglichkeiten, die Argentinier sagen halt, es kann nicht sein, dass du so ein Spiel nach Europa oder aus Südamerika rausverlegst. Und damit, also ich bin da, ich gehe auch d'accord, ich finde es auch. Also richtig, dass das nicht in River oder wenn in River, also im Monumental, dann ohne Zuschauer, kein Zuschauer erlauben, dann sollen sie halt voll in Rängen spielen. Oder halt, ja, dann geh halt nach Paraguay oder nach Brasilien oder wie auch immer, aber lass diesen Pokal in Südamerika spielen. Und was ist das denn auch für die Mannschaften? Wenn ich sehe, Boca ist dann irgendwie nachts geflogen, beide sind am Mittwoch geflogen, Boca ein bisschen früher, River erst dann so gegen Mittags. Weißt du, du fliegst dann von Sommer in den Winter und hast dann irgendwie zwei, drei Tage, um dich zu akklimatisieren, bleibst für ein Spiel. Ja, ich weiß nicht, da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, da hat das Geschäft Fußball irgendwo gewonnen, aber die Fans, da ist ja auch kaum einer wirklich aus Buenos Aires hingeflogen.
Das wollte ich dich schon fragen, wer da im Stadion war eigentlich.
Du hast ja sehr viele Argentinier in Spanien. Von der FID war das natürlich super, aber ich sag mal so, wenn du ein Ticket hast und du musst jetzt kurzfristig mal nach Spanien fliegen oder so, gerade wenn du die wirtschaftliche Lage in Argentinien ist ja auch mehr als angespannt und das kannst du dir ja gar nicht leisten. Also das war ja im Vorfeld auch schon klar und die sind natürlich auch froh, dass diese ganzen Leute haben so noch ein paar mehr Tickets verkloppen können da in Madrid. Aber die haben eh nur 5000 sowieso bekommen pro Club und das ist ja auch irgendwie, das geht ja eigentlich auch nicht. Also ich weiß nicht, ich fand's einfach nur schade und letztendlich dieses Jahrhundertspiel, was es ja doch irgendwo war, das danach Madrid zu verlegen, das hat dann auch irgendwie den ganzen Zauber genommen und ja, deswegen du musstest jetzt als River, aus Riversicht, zu dieser ultimative Siegwass halt eben nicht. Dann hättest du zu Hause feiern wollen. Und die Boca-Fans werden immer sagen, ja gut, wenn wir das in eurem Stadion gespielt hätten, hätten wir euch geschlagen, so auf die Art. Also du hast jetzt irgendwie so eine Ausrede auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite so einen kleinen Fleck auf diesen tollen Erfolg.
Aber es wird beim Sieg bleiben. Also du siehst jetzt keine Möglichkeit, dass Boca vor irgendein Gericht zieht und sagt, der Titel muss uns anerkannt werden, weil das ist ja Wettbewerbsverzerrung.
Ja, das werden die vielleicht probieren. Ich glaube, ich habe das nicht mal weiterverfolgt nach dem Finale. Ja, weil da gibt es keine Erfolgsschancen für Boca, weil die Sache ist durch. Es wurde gespielt, es wurde zugestimmt. Boca probiert da halt irgendwie, weil der Präsident natürlich auch ein bisschen ein komischer Typ ist, an Helige und will da irgendwie seine Muskeln spielen lassen. Aber das Ding ist durch. Wir haben es verloren und sie haben es zu Recht verloren. Da kann man Griva Nobel Glück wünschen. Boca sagen, so darf es da halt kein Finale spielen. Das geht nicht.
Was sagt denn jetzt die Art und Weise, wie das alles gehandhabt wurde über die beteiligten Verbände aus? Dass wir alle nicht die höchste Meinung von der FIFA haben, zumindest jeder Mensch, der sich schon mal 3 Sekunden mit der FIFA beschäftigt hat, das ist ja klar. Auch die kommende Bowl, da ist sogar noch mehr juristisch nachgewiesen durch die FIFA-Prozesse, unter anderem, wer sich dafür interessiert, kann das entsprechende Tribünen-Gespräch hören. Da habe ich das mal ausführlich mit Jürgen Kalver aufgearbeitet. Aber rund um die Absage gab es ja schon viel vermeintliche Infantino-Einmischung, der gesagt haben soll, es müsse gespielt werden entgegen den Willen der Spieler. Da gab es große Aufregung. Das war aber alles auch so im Laufe dieses Abends. Und da muss man auch vorsichtig sein, weil da setzt ein Journalist einen Tweet ab, von dem er ehrlich gesagt auch weiß, dass alle genau das hören wollen. Nämlich Infantino sagt, es müsse stattfinden, egal wie schlecht es den Boca-Spielern geht. Und dann verselbstständigt sich sowas. Im Nachgang jetzt, diese Entscheidung nach Madrid zu gehen, wie es jetzt alles ablief und wie man das jetzt abgewickelt hat. Findest du, die Verbände haben da eine gute Figur gemacht? Hat man es jetzt letztendlich dann doch gut über die Bühne gebracht? Das Wichtigste war ja, dass das Spiel sportlich irgendwie stattfindet. Oder wie würdest du das einschätzen als jemand, der das ja noch enger verfolgt?
Also das Spiel wurde gespielt. Von daher, also Ziel erfüllt.
Ich spüre aber eigentlich gewissen Wiederwillen.
Ja klar, weil, ja ne, also, die Verbände, ich finde, das geht gar nicht. Also dieser ganze Prozess, wie das passiert ist, diese ganzen Entscheidungen und ja, natürlich muss man da vorsichtig sein. Wir waren alle nicht dabei, wir wissen nicht, ob was gesagt hat in Fantino. Aber es gibt ja auch viele Stimmen, die das ja mehr oder weniger bestätigt haben und auch Boca-Spieler, die darüber geredet haben, die ja danach, wo es dann hieß, ja okay, die sollen gesperrt werden für das 2. Finale, weil sie schlecht über Comevol geredet haben.
Das habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen, ist ja Wahnsinn.
Doch, doch, Tevez, Pablo Pérez, es waren drei Boca-Spieler, wo drüber geredet wurde, dass die dann eventuell gesperrt werden sollen wegen Kritik an Comevol. Wer zufällig das Spiel in de Beniente gegen Boca gesehen hat, da war einmal kurz nach wieder an Pfiff, also es war ja eine Woche vor dem Rückspiel der Libertadores, da war einmal so ein Banner entgegen Comevol zu lesen und das Spiel wurde gar nicht wieder angepfiffen, bis dieser Banner weg war. Und da siehst du auch mal, die Comevol, die ist irgendwie so, die macht so viele zwielichtige und dubiose Aktionen und Entscheidungen, aber ist halt auch überhaupt nicht kritikfähig und diese ganze, ich weiß nicht, dieser ganze Weg zu diesem Rückspiel, der ist gepflastert eigentlich mit irgendeiner fettern Wirtschaft, Geld machen und es lässt sich ein Skandal, also anders. Also ich hab das, ich seh das für mich so gerne, kann das jemand anders sehen und sagen, ey ist doch cool, das war in Madrid, das ist ein tolles Stadion ist es ja auch und wir haben jetzt einen Sieger und das ist doch das Wichtigste und jetzt kann man natürlich auch die Club-WM und bla und bla und hin und her, aber für mich ist das ja das ging gar nicht. Cromwell Ball ist eine Witzfigur, AFA genauso und die FIFA, die steht halt nochmal drüber und die ist halt, hat halt auch irgendwie ich will jetzt nicht sagen kriminelle Energien hier und da, aber es geht alles halt Geschäft, es geht um die Kohle und da ist dann auch irgendwie jedes Mittelrecht und es wird dann wenig Rücksicht genommen und allein, dass du dich hinstellst zu sagen ey, ihr müsst heute spielen, sonst verliert ihr das Spiel und das als FIFA-Chef, sofern er es gesagt hat.
Ja gut, also es gibt viele Zitate, die dir stützen, da hast du schon recht. Ich wollte nur quasi darauf hinweisen, dass nicht alles, was man bei Twitter auch gerade live zu so einem Spiel liest, immer hundertprozentig stimmen muss, weil man sollte quasi dann nicht aufhören, sich mit Themen zu beschäftigen, sondern auch noch ein paar Tage später gucken, was haben denn jetzt dann Journalisten, die recherchieren, auch tatsächlich rausgefunden, was ist belegbar? Das wollte ich sagen. Aber ja, ich meine, es ist ja schon allein durch diese, es ist ja nicht mehr Ironie, dass die Copa Libertadores in dem Land, in der Hauptstadt des Landes stattfindet, von denen man sich damals befreien musste. Also das ist ja auch schon nicht mehr witzig. Das ist ja auch unglaublich. Und dass man das eben rausverlegt aus der Zeitzone, aus den klimatischen Bedingungen. Also eben weil es so viele andere Stadien gab, die sich auch angeboten haben, hätte man da auch Wege gegen können, die näher an der Situation gewesen wäre, wie dieses Spiel eben einfach in Argentinien im El Monumental gespielt worden wäre. Und da hat man sich dagegen entschieden. Und ja, es liegt sehr nahe, dass da verschiedene Gründer eine Rolle gespielt haben, die mit dem Sportlichen gar nicht so viel zu tun haben.
Genau, ja, so kannst du es sagen.
Was meinst du denn jetzt, wenn wir den größeren Rahmen aufmachen, wie das jetzt weitergeht im argentinischen Fußball und was jetzt dieser Super-Klassico, auf den wir uns alle so gefreut hatten, was dem nachhinein bewirkt hat? Weil die Aufmerksamkeit war auf einmal da und ich hatte auch den Eindruck, es war so fast der Klassiker. Die Aufmerksamkeit am Tag, als das Endspiel hätte stattfinden sollen und es wurde verschoben, war höher meinem Empfinden nach, als dann jetzt das eigentliche, als das Spiel gespielt wurde. Was glaubst du macht das mit dem argentinischen Fußball im Ansehen und vielleicht auch in seiner zukünftigen Entwicklung?
Also es war, es ist auf jeden Fall ein großer Schaden, das als allererstes Mal, was da entstanden ist, allein durch diese Aktion, was ja trotzdem auch schade ist, weil es ist ja eigentlich nur, ja, eine Handvoll Fans, eine schlechte Planung, ob jetzt gewollt oder nicht, dass der Bus jetzt da unbedingt vorbeifahren muss. Und dieses eigentliche Fußballfest ist ja von, sagen wir mal, 99,9 Prozent der Leute da entgegen gefiebert wurde. Das ist halt nicht passiert und das ist halt einfach total schade. Und ich glaube auch, dass der argentinische Fußball dadurch, ja, der wird sich da so schnell nicht erholen. Weil du musst dich halt auch echt jetzt fragen, wie im Sinne von Argentinien überhaupt so ein Spiel bei uns auszurichten, ohne dass so was passiert. Argentinien ist jetzt seit fünf Jahren ohne Auswärtsfans. Wo man gedacht hat, wo man gehofft hat, hier und da bei manchen Spielen werden sie jetzt wieder zugelassen, dass sich so was bessert, dass man wieder zurückkommt zu einer gewissen Normalität. Und dann hast du diesen Höhepunkt und kannst eigentlich der ganzen Welt zeigen, ey, ist doch nicht alles so scheiße bei uns im Fußball. Und dann schaffst du es halt irgendwie, das ist, also setzt dem ganzen noch die Krone auf. Und ja, riesiger Imageverlust, auch für die Spieler. Ich meine, stell dir mal vor, du bist so ein ja, so ein Nandes, Barrios oder auch Teves oder so, die halt auch schon große Turniere gespielt haben oder bei europäischen Top-Clubs waren, so Teves beispielsweise. Das ist ja, das ist ja total, ja, das ist ja Amateur-Organisation, so was geht nicht. Und das ist ja auch für die anderen südamerikanischen Talente, die ansonsten gerne nach Argentinien kommen, die sehen das ja auch und denken sich, sag mal, was ist denn eigentlich bei denen los? Die schaffen es ja nun nicht mal, ein Finale dazu organisieren. Ich meine, eine Woche später, der G20-Gipfel, ist ja ganz gut gelaufen, also es geht ja. Ich weiß nicht, es ist alles sehr komisch. Zum Beispiel auch der Klassiker aus Rosario, der wurde ja auch nicht in Rosario gespielt. Er wurde da in der Hauptstadt gespielt, in Buenos Aires, ohne Fans. Das ist ja auch noch passiert, das ist ja gar nicht so lange her.
Präventiv war das oder gab es da auch konkrete Vorfälle?
Ja, Vorfälle gibt es da immer.
Aber das ist ja dann die eigentliche Wurzel des Problems. Also jetzt auch unabhängig davon, wie wir jetzt alles rund um den Superklassik und die Copa Libertadores bewerten, das grundsätzliche Problem scheint ja zu sein, dass es eben eine Gewalt in Fan-Kreisen gibt und dass man der nicht Herr wird. Und wenn man jetzt so lange auch schon keine Gäste-Fans zulässt, dann kann man ja auch zum Beispiel sagen, also diese Sanktion, diese Bestrafung der vielen für das Fehlverhalten der hoffentlich wenigen, das hat ja zu keiner Verbesserung geführt. Was kann man denn tun, deiner Meinung nach, um das irgendwie wieder in geordnete Bahnen zu lenken? Oder ist das komplett unmöglich?
Ich glaube, kurzfristig wird da nichts passieren. Oder kann da nichts passieren, weil zum Beispiel auch einer der Werfer, der da mit Steinen geworfen hat, das war ja jetzt auch keiner aus der Ultra-Szene oder aus der Bra-Bra-Bra-Szene. Das war ja ein normaler Fan.
Aber wird so jemand dann z.B. strafrechtlich belangt?
Also wer weiß, was dann wirklich hinter den Kulissen genau passiert, aber offiziell schon. Ich denke, da wird schon was passieren. Aber ich habe so das Gefühl, dieser Täter an sich ist ja irgendwie austauschbar. Das Problem ist halt einfach ein gesellschaftliches. Ich glaube einfach nicht, dass man das so schnell irgendwie in den Griff bekommt. Das ist halt auch gerade, ich meine, was bekommst du vorgelebt? Gerade im Land wie Argentinien, wo halt die Politik und Wirtschaft geklingelt wird und korrupt ist ohne Ende. Ich meine, wenn du es nicht vorgelebt bekommst, dann kannst du ja auch von deinen Leuten nicht erwarten, dass die immer hier zackzack nach der Reihe tanzen. Da muss halt einfach mal ein richtiges Umdenken her. Weiß ich nicht, ob das so schnell möglich ist. Ich kann dir aber im Umkehrschluss auch sagen, die Gewalt an sich ist ja auch nicht weniger geworden. Also in den letzten fünf Jahren, da hast du halt Konflikte innerhalb der Fanszene, weil es da halt um Macht, Geld, Drogen und alles Mögliche geht. Das sind der richtige Schwarzmarkt in verschiedenen Bereichen, die da kultiviert wurden und die jetzt einfach groß sind. Wo kein Club irgendwie her der Lage ist. Da gibt es ja so viele Beispiele in den letzten Jahren, wo Präsidenten, Manager, auch Spieler einfach von den Buddas gekickt wurden, bedroht wurden und was auch immer.
Sind das die Udras-Organisationen?
Genau, diese Hooligans, Udras, die heißen in Südermärk Abadabrava, sind auch ein bisschen anders organisiert. Also kann es jetzt nicht eins zu eins vergleichen. Ist eine Spur schlimmer, würde ich immer behaupten. Und hat schon mehr kriminelle Energie.
Aber ist es dann überhaupt noch ein Problem, das der Fußball hat in Argentinien? Weil es hört sich fast so an, als ob generell das Land und die Bevölkerung so viele Probleme hat. Und dass wir das jetzt anhand dieser Ausschreitungen rund im Umfeld des Fußballs nachvollziehen können. Aber es hört sich ehrlich gesagt nach einer größeren Thematik an.
So ist es auch. Das ist ja nur ein Spiegel. Also der Fußball, das ist klar, das ist Volkssport. Die Leute, die sind total fanatisch. Gerade die Argentinier, die haben das ja in ihren Genen drin. Also sehr fanatisch zu sein, unabhängig mal vom Fußball. Und ja, das ist ein größeres Problem. Also das ist nicht nur ein rein Fußballer-Problem. Das ist gesellschaftlich vor allem. Und das hat auch politische Auswirkungen, weil ja viele Präsidenten in den diversen Clubs haben ja politische Ämter und dementsprechend politische Gegner. Oder sie brauchen Wählerstimmen oder wie auch immer. Und dann ist es natürlich auch nicht so schlecht, wenn du so ein paar Handlanger hast, die dann irgendwie mal ein paar tausend Leute mobilisieren können und dann mal, was weiß ich, hier mach mal die Landstraße zu, geh mal hier vor, in Buenos Aires pack dir 5000 Mann ein und mach da mal Radau gegen den und den politischen Gegner, den ich hab oder wie auch immer, Kampagne. Es ist halt einfach, es ist halt auch alles schon passiert dahingehend. Und ja, du hast halt jetzt auch Mauricio Marquez, der acht Jahre Präsident von Boca Juniors. Und danach war er Bürgermeister von Buenos Aires und ist jetzt Präsident von Argentinien. Und so, also diese politischen Figuren in Argentinien, die haben alle, sind die irgendwie mit irgendwelchen argentinischen Clubs verbundelt und haben da Ämter oder haben da irgendwelche Interessen und so. Und die Barabrava oftmals, sind halt irgendwelche Handlanger für diese Leute.
Das heißt, man kann eben auch nicht sagen, das ist jetzt eben ein, kriegt mal euren Fußball in den Griff, sondern das wird quasi nicht gehen, wenn sich nicht die Gesamtsituation in Argentinien verdreht. Und dann reden wir über Prozesse. Da werden wir jetzt nicht im nächsten Frühjahr zusammen einen Kurzpass aufnehmen und du wirst mir sagen, Mensch, alles ist super auf einmal, sondern das wird halt jetzt lange, lange dauern, wenn sich was zum Guten hin verändert.
Genau, wird lange dauern und die Polizei spielt dann auch nochmal eine Rolle. Es ist einfach ein riesiges Problem, wie gesagt, in der Gesellschaft auch verankert und die Systeme, die da einfach über die Jahre gewachsen sind, die jetzt einfach auch niemand mehr so richtig kontrollieren kann. Und dann hast du halt so Auswirkungen. Wie gesagt, solche Zähne sieht natürlich keiner gerne, aber gehören leider im argentinischen Fußball auch irgendwie dazu. Also ich kann mich erinnern, ich war mal bei einem Zweitligaspiel bei San Telmo. Die haben den Abstieg gespielt damals und haben irgendwie die siebte Niederlage in Folge kassiert. Und dann waren dann irgendwie die 200 Leute, die –Barabraba, wenn du so willst, das ist auch in so einer, in Isla Maciel heißt das, da steht das Heimstadion, das ist so richtig so ein Armenviertel. Und dann wollten die halt zu den Spielern, wollten da keine Ahnung, irgendwie ein bisschen Druck ausüben, vielleicht auch ein paar Pissos abstauben, weil sie Scheiße gespielt haben und wie auch immer. Und dann wollten die dann in den Innenraum und dann hat sich die Polizei dann halt hingestellt und hat die dann so mit Gummi geschossen, also aus dem Stadion rausgeballert, also ich hab sowas noch nie gesehen. Also Tür zu und dann war dann irgendwie zwei Sekunden war dann so stille und dann alles, was nicht nid und nagelfest war, da war so eine vier Meter hohe Mauer oder so und drum herum halt so ein rurales Gebiet, wo halt überall irgendwelche Steine und irgendwelches Zeug liegt. Und dann ist das alles geflogen gekommen. Und die Polizei hat ja auch nichts Besseres zu tun dann, als diese ganzen Steine einfach wieder zurückzuwerfen. Und dann, weißt du, da kommst du von einem Problem ins nächste und manchmal weißt du auch gar nicht so genau, wer von denen hat jetzt da irgendwie angefangen.
Es geht irgendwann auch nicht mehr darum, wer angefangen hat. Irgendwann kriegst du es nur noch zu lösen, wenn, das ist ja ein ganz viel in verhackten Konflikten, irgendwann kann sich diese Spirale nur noch zurückdrehen, wenn einer freiwillig einen Schritt zurückgeht und einfach darauf vertraut, auf den Gegenüber, in den er eigentlich überhaupt keinen Vertrauen mehr hat, dass der jetzt dann auch einen Schritt zurückgeht. Das siehst du in jedem Vertragtenkonflikt, das ist fürchterlich und dazu sind Menschen nicht bereit, überall auf der Welt, im Kleinen wie im Großen. Meine Güte, ist das jetzt deprimierend geworden, Andreas?
Das ist ja fürchterlich. Total, siehst du mal, was ich über was ich nachdenken muss, die letzten zwei, drei Wochen, die ganze Zeit.
Ja, das glaube ich. Ich kann es jetzt auch nochmal ein bisschen besser nachvollziehen und ich hatte auch schon viele Dinge über Argentinien im Kopf, aber ich versuche mich immer nicht von Vorurteilen leiten zu lassen, also hohe Kriminalitätsrate und so weiter und so fort. Und das jetzt aber dann doch von einem Kenner indirekt nochmal bestätigt zu bekommen, dass die Probleme größer sind, dass es dann nicht nur um den Fußball geht, sondern dass der Fußball eher ein Beispiel dafür ist, wie groß die Probleme der Menschen vor Ort sind. Das ist einfach deprimierend, drüber zu sprechen. Aber hilft ja auch nichts, es droht zu schweigen. Wir können auch nicht immer nur über den schönen Fußball reden und alles andere ausblenden. Ich habe ja auch das Gespräch geführt. Ich hätte nach dem sportlichen Teil einfach Schluss machen können. Und alles andere nur für Supporterinnen und Supporter. Das wäre dann die Paywall. Da zahlst du dafür, dass du die schlechten Nachrichten hörst. Ich finde aber, Andreas, wir sollten immer mal wieder zusammen sprechen. Immer mal wieder, wenn es vielleicht Anlässe gibt, mal auf den argentinischen und südamerikanischen Fußball zu gucken. Ich finde es hochspannend. Es ist auch eine Welt, die einem selbst ein bisschen ferner ist. Es ist wesentlich schwieriger, dazu zu recherchieren als zu anderen. Ich war auf der Gekommene-Bowl-Seite und entweder war ich zu doof, und die haben keine englische Sprache-Variante.
Das ist Wahnsinn, was ich finde. Bei der AFA ist es genauso. Erglaubst du auch, die haben das irgendwann mal in den 90er-Jahren programmiert? Seitdem ist es so.
Ich dachte am Anfang erst, ich wäre auf einer Fan-Seite gelandet und hätte irgendwie einen falschen Link bei Google angeklickt. Aber fürchterlich. Dementsprechend schwierig ist es in diesem Bereich zu recherchieren. Dazu bin ich des Spanischen nur. Ich hatte es zwei Jahre in der Schule. Buscula Playa, sorry, Max, das kann ich sagen. Aber das hilft einem dann auch nicht weiter. Ich würde mich freuen, wenn wir den südamerikanischen Fußball immer mal wieder in den Rasenfunk holen können. Dann werden wir auch schöne Anlässe finden. Das nehmen wir uns ganz fest an.
Hoffentlich.
Sehr, sehr gut. Ansonsten kann man dir auf Twitter folgen. FunTheGuyp heißt du dort. Und man kann sich auch deine Doku angucken. Die werde ich nochmal verlinken. In den Show Notes sehr empfehlenswert. Da bekommt man dann auch so ein bisschen mit von dem Lebensgefühl, was man im Fußball in Argentinien hat. Und nicht nur die negative Seite, sondern da ist es dann viel Positives.
Es ist auch sehr viel Positives. Ich meine, ich habe bei unserem ersten Gespräch ja auch viel darüber erzählt.
Genau.
Trotz dieser ganzen schlimmen Geschichten, es ist sehr viel Leidenschaft drin. Und er kann unglaublich viel Spaß machen, dieser südamerikanische oder argentinische Fußball. Und jetzt sind wir gerade in einem Moment angelangt, wo es halt jetzt immer gerade am Tiefpunkt angelangt.
Hoffentlich ist es der Tiefpunkt. Und dann geht es ab jetzt nur noch nach oben. Gut, Andreas, ich danke dir ganz herzlich. Schön, dass du wieder mal mit dabei warst. Und danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war Kurzpass Nummer 107. Wer es noch nicht gehört hat, gestern ging Kurzpass 106 online. Da haben wir über die Major League Soccer gesprochen. Auch ein höhenswertes Gespräch, wie ich finde. Wobei ich es natürlich auch gut finden muss, ist ja klar. Ich habe ja einen Teil des Gesprächs getragen. Ansonsten gibt es drei Schlusskonferenzen nächste Woche. Also, ihr habt viel zu tun. Bis dann, macht's gut, ciao!
Danke, Max.